what a weird thing we're doing right now
man this is the best thing i've made in
my life maybe the earth is uh flat
[Music]
how's it going
so logan paul texted us
logan paul he asked us to do some effect
shots for him for a project coming up
that he's working on i said sure but in
exchange would you be willing to appear
on our podcast seems like a good trade
and he said yes uh
and now i have to ask ren to do visual
effects for logan paul
so let's uh see this
hey jake
hey ran
what up niko
um
i have a task for you uh something i
could use your help we uh we had a
person reach out to us
and
um
in exchange for them coming onto our
podcast
uh i told them we'd do a couple visual
effects shots for a project they're
working on would you mind doing some
effect shots for logan paul's flat earth
documentary
i guess i'll be doing that well uh
we need to build like a really nice flat
earth
model and there's like a title card
sequence where like we're just looking
for big title floating space like made
out of like dirt and stuff and yeah it's
just like four or five shots no making a
flat earth model isn't that big of a
deal because you know it's fake
it's not big
what it's not good
he said it's not fake
cool well i'm glad you're willing to
help out it's uh
it's a big help from the team
thanks ryan thanks ryan
i hope you guys don't understand yeah um
regarding the the flat earth model um do
we basically have free reign to kind of
just model it however we see fit
artistically like there's different like
there's ones that like domes of air
there's ones that are just flat with the
atmosphere there's ones that have almost
like a big rocky stalactite coming off
the bottom those are the ones that are
flat yeah so once the question yes
there's a lot of creative freedom the
golden one would be the ice shelf so i i
would say the biggest one would be water
not falling off is it flat earth circle
or is it like also rectangular like do
they actually believe in it or are they
just kind of like following along with
the meme what do flat earthers think
happens when they fly from california
over to like japan do you want the north
pole in the center how many people did
you guys actually meet that actually
believe this the whole convention was
filled
about 2-3 000 people
and that wasn't even a major convention
it was like a minor convention
it's crazy
is it
so i think the process here is we'll
mock up the shots
and we'll send you guys like animation
mockups as we are getting them done so
they can get approved and then we'll
render them maybe end of next week thank
you guys we'll talk soon
bye guys later
the things ren does things we make him
do ren why are you in a suit because
it's formal friday hold on
it's formal friday son wait wait wait
wait wait friday
casual every day that's why you make
friday formal scene boy wren so they're
doing a whole mockumentary on flat earth
he started out by saying oh it's 50 50.
he's going to lay out the facts and oh
the earth is around but also going to
lay out all the facts that maybe the
earth is uh flat and i'm like no there
are no facts that the earth is flat so
that's my biggest problem with this
entire thing is i don't want to be like
a vehicle to misinformation i mean we're
basically just doing a title sequence
for what it's worth i know i know i know
i know it's and and also for what it's
worth it'll probably be a pretty sweet
title sequence it will and i think the
nature of it being logan paul like
already makes it into that realm of like
parody you know yeah but logan paul's
audience is very young and susceptible
to believing everything end of next week
we're gonna try to have it done by end
of next week
that shouldn't be too hard it's it's
basically one shot with a bit of a title
flourish at the beginning
a little cross between this and this
what's up steve
hey how's it going i'm just looking for
sam
did you get a permit for that you got to
get a permit for everything oh man
apparently okay
so
sam
hey sam
hey where have you been for the last
hour
uh well uh i'm play testing trucks
basically uh one of the last chapters
we're editing in uh this book here top
10 games you can play in your head by
yourself i'm really excited to share
this with you guys because it's
something we've been working on for a
very very long time and it's finally
being released this march
where do i begin crazy story here so my
friend david and i we're at a garage
sale in uh minnesota and we found these
weird used books basically it was a
series called games you can play in your
head by yourself and as we started going
through them we were realizing these
things are like incredible these these
are basically single player rpgs so to
speak we combed through these things and
uh we weren't able to find much about
the author or whatever but we were able
to basically edit and compile our 10
favorite games the games themselves a
little difficult to understand so it
took a little bit of time for us to go
through them read them play test them i
guess fix them up and we've been
spending since i guess last march i
think we've been just going through
cleaning them up editing them making
them playable that's the most important
part quite fascinating stuff and i
highly recommend that you check out this
book when we release it it's been a
great project and we put a lot of work
into it all right yeah i got a little
more beta testing so to speak watch out
for those aliens out there aliens
spoilers
all right man have fun see ya peace
[Music]
is the sun flat
i don't know i i use questions
carmichael i don't even want to
entertain the answers to these questions
how do you light a flat planet from the
sun your question of like how do you
light it so that half of its night time
and half of its daytime is a
much better question because
how do you what's the hardest thing that
either of you guys have run into
atmosphere yeah just trying to get
atmosphere working and i ended up just
kind of abandoning it because it just
wasn't working and it didn't look good
so but i did manage to get some sort of
uh cloud texture going question what if
the gang rolls up and they're like
change the font
i just changed the font it's as easy as
that i have nine characters there and
each character has a sub character for
the cloud layer so there's 18 characters
in all and i would just switch the font
out for each of those oh so you know you
didn't bake anything in crap what a
weird thing we're doing right now man
logan paul reaches out
hey can you do some vfx for me for my
flat earth mockumentary documentary i
don't know if it's a documentary if he
like legit pretends to believe this or
if like i mean i'm gonna ask him about
the podcast and be like dude what's the
deal man
you guys ready for the interview
basically we're on the last leg of
getting ready for the interview i have
to pee but i will do so in time
probably during the interview someone
like logan paul's a tricky interview
it's a controversial figure and honestly
i have a feeling that most of our
audience isn't really a fan of him that
doesn't mean it can't be interesting you
can listen to someone without agreeing
with them and i think the more
perspectives you listen to the wiser you
become and everybody thinks listening
equals agreeing and that's not the case
at all you will be a smarter person if
you listen to people that you disagree
with if you can't challenge your views
your views aren't worth being held onto
anyways logan paul is going to challenge
our views i want to go down the rabbit
hole of all the old [ __ ] that people
talked about with logan paul i just want
to find out
he's an interesting person he's had an
interesting life good and bad and i want
to talk about that and learn about that
what's up hi what's going on
so
what have you done literally
no way
oh my god
the rocky bottom
this project is the best this is the
best thing i've made in my life i'm
excited to talk about it yeah oh yeah oh
yeah it's crazy dude this looks great
dude this looks great i think one one
note right off the bat is i think the
ice shelf can be brighter and whiter
because i don't think many people know
that flat earthers believe the earth is
surrounded by antarctica okay the ice
shelf so the more just like white and
prominent it can be which is easy yeah
yeah based on the way it looks minus the
brightness are you happy with that or
yeah i do like this is this is beautiful
it's like you're happy with the
topography yeah yeah topography is the
word huh
topography is great typography i really
raised all the landmass like out of the
like south america just like wraps
around this yeah it's great i also added
a random like red light off in the
distance just for style i love it i love
that yes
this is amazing i i don't even know if i
have no it's
beautiful what an awesome client
i'm sure you guys get like bombarded
with notes all the time man yeah like
i'm sure
i'm gonna be honest
i'm a note freak dog like normally i
have notes
but i got no notes
that's good some notes make some notes
make you better though that's what makes
it even more aggravating it's like deep
down you know they're right
hey yep i've been there i've been there
well we'll start getting renders out
thank you
yeah yeah thank you bro appreciate you
guys let me know where it goes live uh
yeah it'll be in a week we can a half
next wednesday yeah should be posted all
right all right sounds good take care
set up the animations render this thing
all right
so the podcast we just recorded logan
paul is live right now on the corridor
cast it's the first link in the
description below on the corner cast to
try to have interesting people with
interesting answers to our interesting
questions go check it out it's
youtube.com quartercast probably an
annotation on the screen here or first
link in the description below of course
you can listen to it anywhere you like
to listen to your podcasts enjoy